but by the way how are things in
california right now
you know you and i texted back and forth
the other day with the whole greats
where they're getting rid of
f's and some lausd and these right some
cities they're not going to do these but
how are things with crime street i mean
you've seen a lot of videos people are
walking and taking stuff but we're not
living in california you're there what
is it dallas texas too i i know four
people that have been either held up had
a gun pointed at them something violent
a violent encounter and this this is in
beverly hills this is in the pacific i
personally know them i personally know
people have had guns pulled on them
robberies around them you know i was
making a movie with alec baldwin
no actually he took a sabbatical um wow
we had a christmas party last week a
good friend in beverly hills and
literally i was thinking about it all
day i was thinking is there going to be
security there because literally they're
they're hitting holiday parties now
they'll come in
and they'll they'll watch his wallets
and rings it's happening it really is
and i literally asked him i said by the
way is there going to be security there
have they thought about hiring somebody
luckily it was in an enclosed condo
complex where you couldn't get in but i
was literally thinking about that all
day i think about that where where you
drive where you go people don't wear
their watches they don't wear they don't
carry expensive things you're you're a
walking target
and it's just it's really sad you know
they had huge smash and grabs over
thanksgiving like a lot of these big
cities did they rounded up they arrested
17 people garcetti goes in front of this
big press conferences they were all
released the next day zero cash bonds
it's really bad they're so brazen they
don't care they're organized and i think
it's starting to hit more influential
people in california that's why i think
it might start shifting a little bit
because it just makes no sense if you
think back and then these they can go in
and steal whatever they want whenever
they want
in the most high traffic areas it's a
great time for for citizen watches to
create a marketing campaign wear our
watches no one will steal them
like a very it's a exactly like the old
swatch from 40 years ago
hey pat you know we're talking about the
smashing grab you know the nordstroms
that's at west hills yeah that's right
it's on topanke canyon and it's the edge
of canoga park but it's right by west
hills and
where all the celebs live you know
calabasas it was right next to that
that was the nordstrom that was hit so
they're coming to these areas
that's right and it's now known as the
westfield west hills
that's the one that got hit so when
there was police cars chasing them it
was a huge it was a challenge this is
not an isolated incident when
nordstrom's reported their earnings they
had a special line item for theft that's
how much it's impacted nordstrom's
earnings they had a special one-line
item for losses due to that and
walgreens has shut down hundreds of
stores because of that yeah and it's
it's organized the uh the topanga one
happened this way
first three came in with bear spray and
they hit the guards they walked in and
this was two girls one guy dressed
reasonably they
they had like you know they were wearing
like
caps and then pulled them down and then
he hit the guards with the bear spray
and then 20 people stream in and got all
the purses and stuff that can be sold
easily on ebay or with sidewalk vendors
down in venice hey you want a purse
yeah i mean it had a method point is
there is a playbook for this it wasn't
just random i talked to i talked to uh a
big uh pr from yesterday in new york and
this is how the call starts
so uh um my friend said you ought to get
with one of these bigger pr firms this
is the main person you gotta talk to us
and no problem so she gets on
and uh
uh she says uh so how are things great
so where you at i'm like i'm in south
florida you know things are great here
oh i hear things about south florida i'm
like what do you hear about south
florida it's okay i said how are things
in new york oh great i said oh you know
it's great to be a part of it that was
the best city in the world just a couple
years ago pre-covered oh stop
exaggerating still the greatest city i
was on the streets the other day people
are walking everywhere it's so free it's
still the greatest city in the world i'm
like yeah there's a lot of strange
things going on there and you saw her
like she couldn't help herself no this
is still the greatest city in the world
and she's going with this part i'm like
all right i said well awesome you know
more power to the great city there are
certain people that are trying to deny
what's going on in their cities new york
being one of them la being one of them
and the
newsome even came out and said i'm going
to follow uh what do you call it's a
protocol he says what texas is doing
with abortion i'm going to be doing with
gun laws is what we're going to be doing
remember yeah he's ramming that through
to get rid of the automatic assault
rifles right in in l.a anyways
again they keep doing things like this
people are going to keep leaving people
will react there is cause and effect i
was i was in new york city yesterday i
mean i heard from a lot of my buddies no
i'm i'm i'm back back working at home
they shut down the office again because
they they imposed mass mandates inside
yeah
yeah la just shut down for another month
too mass indoors everywhere don't you
just love that it's like a way of saying
go spend time with your family
there's a level of nobility and newsome
when you think about it you know like
these guys are they're so concerned
about your quality time with your family
but and nobility i never i never made
that
yeah it's just it's it's a sweet little
thing that's going on there so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]